The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NATALIE KULDELL: So
we are among friends,
please call me Natalie,
please interrupt me as I go.
Elizabeth has given a very nice
framework for-- the high level
questions about this
next little bit of time
are things about creating
a scalable educational
experience, and
things like that.
But truth be told,
this is really
going to be me,
my dirty laundry,
telling you all
the mistakes I've
made in developing something
that I thought seemed
like a good idea at the time.
How's that as the sort of
tag line for this talk?
It seemed like a good
idea at the time.
But maybe, just so that you
don't go running from the room
and think this is going
to be all disaster,
I will start by showing you
where this has ended up.
Because where all this
meandering and mistake-making
has brought me is to
something that I'm actually
pretty proud of, and that
seems to be reasonably useful.
I don't think this is the final
form of what this will take,
but let's start with
where it ends up,
and then we'll rewind the
tape and go from the beginning
to get it back to here.
So BioBuilder is now a
nonprofit organization
that I am founder of, I have
a wonderful board of directors
that help protect
me and my time,
and help me make good decisions
about protecting just thinking
through the business questions,
and the strategic questions,
and the wisdom questions
that are involved in running
a nonprofit organization.
It came about because I thought
that the teaching I was doing
here at MIT, in the Department
of Biological Engineering,
was such a great way
to teach and to learn.
I was having so much fun drawing
on current research questions
from the department, and
using the questions that
existed to teach
the engineering,
and using the engineering to
teach the science behind it.
So I'm a scientist by
training, not an engineer.
In fact, I didn't
really even appreciate
the distinction between
science and engineering
until I got to MIT 12 years
ago, or something like that.
I really like learning
about how the world works.
What I discovered when
I got here and started
teaching this way
to the undergrads
was that, by building
stuff made from biology,
you learn a lot
about how it works.
And so I really just wanted
to more broadly distribute
that content to students who
wanted to learn this way,
and to teachers who
wanted to teach this way.
Pretty simple-- not
that wise, maybe,
but that's what I've
organized this around.
And so there is a
nonprofit organization that
is called the BioBuilder
Educational Foundation which
has, as I say, a board
of directors, partners,
we have publications and
newsletters and things
like that.
We are a 501(c)3, and
we were founded in 2011.
The funding for
this organization
came from the National
Science Foundation.
They awarded MIT, Harvard,
Stanford, UC Berkeley,
and UCSF-- a consortium
of five institutions--
10 years' worth of funding.
From the NSF, that's
really unheard of.
And I thought, as the
educational director
on the East Coast for
this, with 10 years
of funding we could do
something really, really cool.
And so what that
started with were
animations, which is why I'm
here talking to you today.
What those animations
have been connected into
is a curriculum
for students that
has a number of hands-on
laboratory activities.
So for example, this
one is for students.
These bubbles that are here
link to the animations,
but the content
that's on the website
is some introductory content,
laboratory procedures,
lab report information, and then
a portal for sharing your data
once you've collected it.
There's also a teacher's
component to this website,
so that teachers, if they wanted
to start teaching this content,
would have classroom
materials like PowerPoints
to introduce the content,
videos about introducing
synthetic biology-- which is
what the focus of these labs
are-- and then
components for the lab
introductory PowerPoints
and things like that.
So this is a website
that has information
about the nonprofit
organization,
it has curricular content for
the students-- which are mostly
high school students and
some college students--
and then it also has
a portal for teachers.
We run teacher
workshops in the summers
to train teachers how to
teach this in the classroom,
and how to teach other teachers.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So one of the things
we talked about yesterday was
this notion of a
video being something
more than the experience of just
pressing play and finishing it,
that a video is meant
to spark an ending, that
is the conversation that
happens on comments on YouTube--
we focused a lot on YouTube
and social-media based video.
What is, I guess, the ending
or the goal-- or what's
your vision what an ending
looks like for things
like BioBuilder?
And what's your user pipeline?
Because for us,
we're talking a lot
about people who are
exploring the internet
and finding things that
spark their curiosity
or love of learning.
I would imagine that
something like BioBuilder,
you have a very focused pipeline
that's maybe more looking
at classrooms?
NATALIE KULDELL:
So the distinction
you just made between
the focused pipeline
and the user exploring
through the internet,
is a distinction
that I did not know
when I started this project, but
that has become really clear.
So the pipeline
for this is really
intended to be formal
education setting--
so I don't know if when you
took high school biology,
you took advanced placement
biology or something like
that, there are this
series of lessons and labs.
And these are intended to fit
squarely into formal education
settings, where teachers
have content that they need
to cover, hands-on labs that
teach techniques as well
as investigative
questions, and then writing
and points to
communicate their work.
Originally-- and maybe
this is a good segue
into to how this really
started-- this was my notion.
I don't know if you've ever seen
this website-- I'm sure many
of you have-- BrainPOP.
This was what I thought
the animations were
going to fit into.
This is kind of the
explore the internet
depending on what
you're curious about
kind of sense of the animations
that are in BioBuilder.
So cellular life in
genetics-- and maybe
in watching cellular life
in genetics, a person
would get interested
in something
in particular--
cloning, or whatever.
And so this is a very
rich library of animations
that a person can self-navigate
through, and learn content
that they're particularly
interested in.
And I imagined, when I
started this project,
that I would build a library of
videos that looked like this.
That is not where
I have ended up.
That was, in fact,
really misguided.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: My question is--
you're in the kind of structure
and giving this to
students and teachers,
how do you choose
what to pick as a--
NATALIE KULDELL: As a topic?
Right, so I work with
high school teachers
every summer to
decide on the topics.
The very first thing
that the high school
teachers I've worked with
told me was that they did not
have more time in their
day to teach other stuff,
but that they did
feel that they could
teach what they were
teaching in a better
way, in a more effective way.
And they thought engineering was
a great lens to teach biology,
in particular, and these
current research questions.
AUDIENCE: And they're giving
you the concept that has to be
covered, and you're coming
up with the example that--
are they saying, it would
be nice if we could use this
example for--
NATALIE KULDELL: So it's
more of a partnership
than that, because what
I'll do is I'll say,
here's a really
interesting system that
has an ongoing question
associated with it-- how do
you reliably engineer a cell?
How do you improve
gain in a system?
Something like that.
And they'll say,
oh, well, you know,
I don't really know
much about that topic,
but I have always had trouble
teaching photosynthesis.
So is there a way that we
could teach that question
and cover photosynthesis.
So I'll say, well, in a plant
cell, we could do it this way.
So it's more of
a give and take--
what they have
challenges teaching,
and what are the
ongoing research
questions in this field.
So this kind of BrainPOP
kind of meandering
through a library
of videos is what
I imagined I would be
creating at the beginning
of this 10-year NSF funding.
What I had not
appreciated was how long
it takes to make each video, how
hard it is to make each video,
and how bad I am at
making each video.
So let me just walk you
through the very first video
that I made.
So in preparation for
this conversation,
I went back to some of the
earlier stuff that I had done.
And I'll tell you that
the characters that
are in these videos started
with the characters that
were-- these are all animated
videos, they're all animations.
And the characters
who are in them
started with this
comic strip, which
appeared in the journal,
Nature, in 2005.
So this was the launch
of some of the interest
around the field of
synthetic biology.
There were some splashy
papers in Nature,
as well as this
comic strip, and it
shows the adventures of a woman
in the lab named System Sally,
and a boy who's just super
curious named Device Dude,
and Buddy, who is this little
green blob in the middle there.
And it's a really fun
comic-- I like comics a lot,
I grew up with Spider-man.
I love comic books.
And I like this
one until it gets
to the really hard content.
So right at the fold here,
right at the midpoint,
it starts to talk about
engineered genetic devices.
And I'll pass this around.
There's a lot of
content here, Boolean
logic gates, ribosome
binding sites--
you have to be an
expert to understand
what was going on in that comic.
So my naive thought was, I
would take these characters--
because they were very popular,
people really liked them--
and I would have
dialogue between them
to explain these ideas,
rather than have them
on the page with just bubbles
and question marks and things
like that.
So in a very lucky
way, It turns out
that my college
roommate's husband
runs an animation company.
So that's how I got connected
with animated storyboards.
They gave me a
very nice discount
on what they would do in
terms of these animations--
it was still expensive.
But this was the
transition that was made.
So the comic book turned
into this website,
which was BioBuilder.
This was the very first
iteration of the website.
And it had, on the
left hand panel,
the idea was there would be
science animations, engineering
animations, technology
animations, things like that.
And like BrainPOP site,
you would enter that,
and there would be a whole
library of animations
that you could explore.
In the end, I don't
have enough years
to live to populate the site.
It takes so long to make
each of these animations--
it would take me forever
to really populate
the site for visitors to
self-navigate through the topic
areas.
So this was the original idea.
Then I started working
with a teacher,
and the website
changed to look more
like this-- where
the animations were
put into a formal
context of activities,
there was also a link
where you could go directly
to the animations, if you just
wanted to watch the animations.
So this was sort of the
transition period, where there
was both a library of
animations and activities
that you could do, if you wanted
to teach with these animations.
There were also single-page
comic strips-- so
returning to what was originally
the unsuccessful version--
single-page comic strips that
set up each of the laboratory
activities.
And this was the
transition to, then,
the third version of
the website, which
I showed you at the beginning.
So let me show you, since
you're working on animations
of your own, let me show
you some of the detail, some
of the things that went into
building that very first--
well, let me show you the
first animation I did.
How about that?
I'll show you what these
animations look like,
and then I'll show you some
of the fun and the choices
that went into making this
animation in particular.
Does that sound like
a reasonable plan?
AUDIENCE: This would be a great
review, because on Thursday,
Josh from [INAUDIBLE].
NATALIE KULDELL: Great, great.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BUBBLES]
-Dude , no running
in the laboratory.
-Sorry, Sally-- but have you
heard about this competition?
It's called iGem, and I think my
bacterial bubble could totally
win this year.
-I thought you were done
with bacterial bubbles.
And what do you know about iGem?
-Um, not much, except
that there's going
to be a bunch of losers and me.
-I don't think you understand
the nature of this competition.
iGem-- the International
Genetically Engineered Machine
Competition is a way
to get young scientists
and engineers working together
to engineer biological systems.
-Working together?
Where's the competitive
spirit in that?
The dude works alone, that way
the dude gets all the credit.
-You need to be a member
of a team to join iGem,
and you need a
professor to lead it.
-But I heard it was a
student competition.
-Well, yes, the competition
started in 2004,
based on an undergraduate
class developed at MIT in 2003
for their short winter session.
And it continues to be an
undergraduate experience--
but not without
guidance and support.
Last year, there were
more than 30 teams
who competed from
all over the world.
-So that's my competition?
That's a lot of people.
-A lot of people all
asking the same question--
can simple biological
systems be built
from standard
interchangeable parts,
and operate in living cells?
Or is biology simply
too complicated
to be engineered in this way?
What do you think?
-Biology is not too
complicated for me.
-The goals of this
competition are
to enable systematic
engineering of biology,
promote open and transparent
development of tools
for engineering
biology, and help
construct a society
that can productively
apply biological technology.
-OK, I got a lot of
work ahead of me.
If we're not going to
use my bubble idea,
what else is possible?
-Maybe a better question
would be, what isn't possible?
-OK, so first off, what's
your standard interchangeable
part be?
Actually, what parts exist?
Do we have to make those?
-You'll probably
need more than one,
but the registry of
standard biological parts
is a great resource, with lots
of parts already designed.
And if we make
parts of our own, we
should add them to
the registry, in case
other teams can use them, too.
-And help other teams?
What kind of
competition is that?
Of is that how so many teams got
cool projects going last year?
Pleasant-smelling bacteria,
a bacteria nightlight,
a DNA drug delivery system--
I heard one team even
made up bacterial freeze tag.
To beat those, we should
get started right now.
-All right, well let's
brainstorm for a little while
before I have to
get back to work.
How does that sound?
-Great.
Can you show me this registry?
Maybe we can find some
good parts to use.
-Good idea, Dude.
Let's start there.
This is where you'll
be able to search.
-Oh, wow!
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NATALIE KULDELL: All right,
so that, for better or worse,
is probably the best video
that's on my website.
And you know, it was
done several years ago,
it still holds true.
So in some ways it-- it still
very accurately describes iGem.
It has some old screen
shots of the registry
and things like
that, but you know,
it was done five
years ago and I think
it holds up reasonably well.
It was fun to make, so let me
show you some of the fun things
that were involved in making it.
One thing was the script.
So the script was written by
a former undergrad of mine
in biological engineering, and
she did a summer UROP with me,
and wrote some of these scripts.
And then it was
edited by a woman
who's on my board who
is also a screenwriter.
And this just shows you
some of the edits that were
involved in that short script.
"Dude, no running in the lab.
Sorry, Sally, but have you
heard about this competition?
It's called iGem.
I think my bacterial bubble
could totally win this year."
And she deleted, "I
don't much about it,
but someone gave
me a flyer for it."
So there were a lot of deletions
and edits on the text, itself.
And if you like
writing, and if you
like this kind of
sentence level work,
this is actually pretty
fun and creative.
I'm not very good at it,
but I think it's fun.
The other part that
I would say was
pretty fun was-- oh, before we
did the storyboarding actually,
we did-- where are
those pictures?
Maybe it's here.
Yeah, so the company
that did these animations
sent me pictures of
people who were posing
in ways that they
thought they would
be using in this animation.
And I got to choose
which little boy I wanted
to be Dude in these comics.
So I don't remember which one
I chose, but these are all
shots of actors
that they have who
come in and pose in ways
that they would think
might fit the
script, and then you
get to choose which one they're
going to base the image on.
I also got to choose voices,
and I have an early read-through
here that--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-My bacteria bubble could
totally win this year.
-I thought you were done
with bacterial bubbles.
What do you know about iGem?
-Not much, except that
there's going to be
a bunch of losers, and me.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
NATALIE KULDELL: So that
was a quick read of one
of the candidates for the
voices and stuff like that.
So that was kind of
fun to work with them
to choose actors who
were doing the still
shots, and the voices,
and things like that.
And then they did
the storyboarding
for this animation, which
I had never done before.
They were very talented at--
they knew where to break it up
and which shots they'd use.
And in watching that
video now, and honestly
I don't watch these
videos regularly,
so it's interesting to see
a couple things that I think
still work reasonably well.
I think it's short enough,
it doesn't go on and on--
so could be a
little bit shorter,
but I think it's
pretty interesting.
I think it zooms in
and out of a reality
scene and a non-real scene.
And it covers the
questions they have.
There's a little bit of
lingo and secrecy to it
that's not as easy
to understand,
if you don't already
know iGem a little bit.
But I think it answers
most questions that people
would have about iGem.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why did you choose to
do animations rather than film
a real woman with a boy?
NATALIE KULDELL: I
think I was misinformed,
that I thought animations
would be quicker and easier.
And then I also had
that BrainPOP idea
in mind, and this
comic strip in mind,
which had Buddy, this
sort of bacteria thing,
as one of the characters.
And so I didn't think a puppet
or something would make sense.
But that does lead me to
a mistake that I made.
And again, if I knew
then what I know now--
who's my audience for this?
I mean, would high school
students watch this?
I don't think so.
I think it's too young for high
school students, and too old
for middle school students.
It kind of doesn't
have-- frankly, I
show it to my undergrads, so
I was like, I'm OK with that.
So maybe it's OK
for MIT undergrads,
but then it doesn't really
have a great audience mark.
And the high school teachers
who are now using them,
it's pretty rare.
I mean, they may
assign them to people
to watch the night
before they come in
and start the discussion
on synthetic biology,
or start their iGem team,
but it's not something
they show in the classroom.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what was the
intent behind making it?
Because we talk a lot about what
is going to be your what, why,
and how questions
before you make a video.
Was it to make
something that was
instructional for people
who were already interested
in iGem?
And if so, what
you made you want
to do a video over a
comic book, for instance?
What was that initial interest?
NATALIE KULDELL: I thought-- why
are there all the words listed
in the dictionary?
My goal was to actually
make like a Wikipedia
of synthetic biology,
covering the relevant topics
through animation.
So I wasn't being selective--
I had to choose something
to start with.
iGem was my first, because
it seemed to really capture
some of the unique features
of synthetic biology,
and was explainable in a way.
It's a discrete entity, not
too technical or anything
like that, that I could cover.
But it was really intended to
be encyclopedic, not targeted
to an area that I
wanted to cover--
except synthetic biology.
When I started this
project, people
were coming to me for
learning materials
about synthetic biology,
and some of those people
were people in government
and policy, some of them
were biologists wanting to learn
engineering, and some of them
were engineers wanting
to learn biology.
And I was not going
to make a comment
book, or a different way for
each of those populations
to learn.
I guess my thinking was
that through self-navigation
through animations,
people could learn
what they wanted to learn.
But what it requires is
a really rich library
of animations to look through.
And this took me a
full summer to do,
and I just don't
have that much time.
I mean, I would need
hundreds of animations,
and I just didn't have time.
Then, to top it off, when the
teacher finally came to me
and said, I can't
teach this way.
There's no narrative
to using these.
I need a hook, I
need a something
that introduce to my students.
It has to fit into a framework.
That's when starting
with the research
questions in the field,
and using these animations
to support the
background that you
learn to do the
investigation, just seemed
to make a lot more sense.
So if we look back
to the website,
and we go to the
student side, we
can look at this one--
what a colorful world.
So now the bacterial growth
curves animation is here.
I did, I will say,
introduce another character,
Izzie the iGemmer--
she's Latina,
somebody said you should
have a little diversity.
Anyway, again, it has all kinds
of probably rookie mistakes
that you guys will never
make, thanks to your course
that you're taking now at IAP.
But this is the idea, is that
now these animations don't
stand on their own the
way like BrainPOP does,
and you sort of
meander through them.
Now they're part of
the background material
you can look at and
read and understand,
in order to do some
biodesign, or some experiments
about transformation of
bacteria to different colors,
and things like that.
Were there are other--
tell me what would
be relevant for your work here.
-OK, I was thinking that
since you work so well
with the high school
population, if you could orient
these guys a little bit, since
you work so well with teachers
and the students,
understanding that age range.
Right before you
work with them, which
is our target audience, what
are some science concepts
that those kids-- like
what do they know?
It wasn't that long ago
that you were that age,
but you've done
a lot since then.
You probably forget.
Meeting with the sixth
graders would probably
be very informative to think
about, oh, what do they know,
what don't they know?
But maybe it would be helpful,
since you have a better
understanding of
what's taught when,
for them to have
a sense of-- say
sixth grade is
kind of our target,
what do those kids know,
and what don't they
know about science?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, if I
can add one more thing,
it's really important
because even if-- I mean,
I had you guys meet with
the sixth graders today,
but that doesn't mean that
your videos should be talking
to a ten-year-old, right?
Because that's really
the basic knowledge
base of the average
public view, that they're
not really going to
remember the science
that they learned beyond
middle school or high school.
So don't mistake understanding
an audience of sixth graders
as thinking that it's an
audience of ten-year-olds,
that you're talking to
them like they're 10.
Because the person who
watches Myth Busters,
and the person who goes to
vote on certain policies,
they're going to share
a knowledge base.
So that's why I think it's
important to orient yourself
to that audience.
NATALIE KULDELL: So in terms of
what folks know and don't know,
where this content
currently is positioned
is to fit into the
formal frameworks
that most high schools
teach for biology.
In particular, the advanced
placement biology classes.
And the reason for that is that,
because their laboratory based,
you really kind of need
particular equipment,
you need time in your day
to do this kind of stuff
with them-- if it's a
hands-on lab activity--
and so the advanced placement
curriculum has that built in,
and you can make some
presumptions about what's
available, and what isn't,
what sorts of basic knowledge
they have.
At the high school level,
generally speaking,
there's good abstract thinking.
You can think about things that
you can't see and understand
what's going on with them,
without actually having
to either manipulate them
directly, or visualize
them, have them right
in front of you.
At the middle school level, I
don't know that that's true.
And I will say there is a
BioBuilder junior site that's
quite fledgling, and
not as robust as this,
but that there's
great interest in it.
I mean, you can see the in
sixth-- they're awesome,
these middle schoolers.
They're so curious, and they
really want to do stuff,
and they're not, oh,
I don't like science,
and oh, I never got that.
Or they're not already
turned off in some ways,
they're very open to new ideas.
What's hard, I think, is
the abstract thinking.
So when I tell, in
this lab in particular,
that's here, which is
an experiment which
brings DNA into a cell and
turns the cell different colors.
And the scientific
question here is, does it
matter what cell
type you're using
to get different levels
of color expression?
So like the chassis
in which you're
running this genetic program,
what's the impact of that?
It's a very important
question in the field
of biological
engineering-- what cell
are you going to choose
to run your program in,
and how do you choose it?
This is a typical
transformation experiment
that many schools do
with their students,
but usually schools are doing
it just as a demonstration.
What are you going to do
with a middle schooler
when you say to them, well,
when you add salt to the cell,
the membrane gets porous,
there are tiny holes in it,
and the DNA can sneak through?
They have to buy it.
So some of the middle school
teachers are doing acting out--
they have students
stand in a circle
and hold hands, and say,
OK, now salt's added,
and have some of
the kids let go.
And so I think
working with teachers
who know their audience has
been, for me, critically
important in making this any
kind of success that it is.
And I continue to really
value their advice.
They know what works with their
students and what doesn't.
And these animations,
some of them use them,
but I think they mostly use
them as homeworks, not as ways
to have students discover
what they want to know
about synthetic biology.
AUDIENCE: That's going to be
really important, because some
of you guys have
authentically more
concrete topics than others.
Because ships are
something that you can see.
Computer programming is not.
So you guys, some of you will
have more abstract concepts,
are going to have to really
work hard to figure out,
how do you make that
concrete enough so
that a kid, who developmentally
can't grasp an abstract concept
as easily as someone a
bit older-- how do you
make that with
metaphor, with acting,
with all these different things?
How do you use your
communication tools
to make something
that is maybe a reach
outside of their developmental
conceptual ability,
but is still accessible to them.
AUDIENCE: And I will say
it's that, as a case study
it's very interesting.
So when the MIT K12
Videos program started,
it was originally
allowing students
to create full videos on
their own without production.
And I'll have to show
you this slide, maybe
after Natalie's
talk, but when you
let MIT students decide
what they want to make,
just let them do it free-reign,
almost 70% of the videos
were physics.
It was alarming, the
overwhelming majority.
And it's because physics is
a very visual, very tangible
topic.
And when you go online, a lot
of science videos and a few
are physics-based.
Maybe one was on
electrical engineering.
And the electrical engineering
ones were about circuits,
so again, you could
see the parts.
When we started
producing Science
out Loud, the one video that
went as popular-- in order
of magnitude, at least-- and
the view count [INAUDIBLE],
that's a different discussion.
But the one that did
the best on its own
was the one that I
marketed the least.
I literally just
posted it to YouTube,
and sent one Tweet about it.
And it was one on
how computers work.
And I don't know if you've
been in the Stata Center,
but there's this machine
called the [INAUDIBLE]
which explains how
switches count in binary,
as the fundamental
component of the computer.
And people loved
that video, and it
showed this desire
and this innate need
for a way to visualize these
super abstract concepts.
And the fact that things
that fulfill that need just
don't exist right now.
It's very hard to find a
good video on programming.
It's very hard to find a good
video on biology, actually.
Anything microscopic-- it's
hard to create something that's
visually engaging, to
where you really justify
making a video out of it.
If you ask yourself,
why would I make a video
about microbiology, when it's
so much more clear and so
much more engaging to
write a blog post about it?
And so are the challenges
that come along with it.
And these are very
good questions.
They're very good
mindsets to have
when you approach those ideas.
AUDIENCE: And Elizabeth
had a really--
we had a really interesting
conversation with those girls
about what computer programming
concept was actually
most interesting to them.
What we realized was
that all of these ideas
were really big ideas.
The binary is such
a narrow topic,
that is allows you to flesh
it out in great detail
to show-- for the
different types of learners
who are out there--
different ways
to access that information.
So the challenge is
to pick a topic that's
narrow enough, that
in five minutes,
you can really unpack it
and pack it back up again.
And really targeting our
audience to figure out what do
they know, and what
don't they know,
so that we're hitting that sweet
spot where it's interesting,
complicated, but not
so complicated that I
can't-- it's too much for me.
AUDIENCE: Jaime's original pitch
was almost six minutes long.
And it was about how
does a computer work?
That was his original idea.
And so it hit upon switches.
It hit upon talking about
binary and on semi-conductors
and all these things.
The switches part
is literally less
than a sentence of
his pitch, and that
is what we ended up
exploring for five minutes.
We had so much to say about it.
I do think the more
focused a video is,
it can be a lot more powerful.
Somehow it makes it more dense.
Having worked with
this age group myself,
I remember sixth grades
learning basic biology--
just so you guys can
orient yourselves.
Seventh grade is learning
basic structures, typically,
like how to build a
bridge, and how to keep
something physically standing.
Fifth grade is-- I'm
trying to think backwards.
Eighth is-- chemistry.
So just so that you guys
have a sense of where
they are in their
learning, they're
really sticking
with physical things
until they get a
little bit bigger,
and can conceptualize chemistry.
They're not even ready,
yet, to think about that
until about eighth
grade-- is like 14.
NATALIE KULDELL: So maybe in
the last just minute or so,
I'll show you another
video that's not very good.
But that does really
speak to this question
of how I'm trying to visualize
something that is microscopic,
and what we did with animation
to try to accomplish that.
And we won't look
at all of this.
But we'll get to the
microscopic part.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Dude, I like what
you built there.
What's it do?
-Oh, hi, Iz.
This is a cool bug-- I made
it using in an electronics
building kit that Sally got me.
She wanted to get
me a genetics kit,
but nothing's available yet.
Eesh-- I don't get it.
Why is it so easy
to turn on and off
the lights for this electronic
bug, but so hard to turn things
on and off in biology?
-What do you mean, Dude?
The arsenic sensor that
we built in bacteria
a few years ago
works pretty well.
If there's arsenic in
the water being tested,
the sensor turns on.
And when arsenic isn't in
the water, the sensor is off.
And we built that sensor with
natural biological parts.
-So arsenic works
like this switch?
How is that possible?
How does the cell know?
-We used parts from
the ArsR operon
to program arsenic
inducible expression.
-Hold up, arsenic
inducible expression?
What's that mean?
All I know is that
arsenic is toxic.
Don't the cells just die
when you poison them?
-Cells have to come up
with a bunch of clever ways
to survive.
In the case of
arsenic, the cells
make a pump to
get the poison out
as soon as any comes
inside the cell.
-So asser is the pump.
-Dude, be careful
how you say it.
The protein is called
ArsR, since it's
the arsenic repressor protein.
And ArsR isn't the pump--
it just tells the cell
when to make the pump.
The operon has a promoter,
which is where the cell's RNA
polymerase binds.
And at least three
genes, ArsR gene,
which encodes the
repressor protein,
and the ArsB gene
which encodes the pump,
and the ArsC gene, which
encodes an enzyme that
reduces arsenic in the cell,
so it can be pumped out.
-Oh, OK, right.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NATALIE KULDELL: OK,
so you get the idea.
It just goes on
from there, and it
talks about how you build
an inverter by moving
the repressor and the
promoter in different spots,
and manipulate the DNA.
But you can see
with this one, you
know there was some
physical object
that we were trying to use to
illustrate what a switch does.
But then when you get
down to that DNA level,
and you're talking about
proteins binding to DNA,
and names of open reading frames
and stuff, it's just deadly.
I mean, I can't even watch
it and I know this stuff.
So I guess it's a real
challenge-- it's a hard thing
to think about making tangible,
making evident, things
that are not.
But I do think there's a great
power through storytelling,
through animation, through
video that you have,
and when it's done well
it's really very, very
effective, and very memorable,
I think is the big part of it.
Are there any other
quick questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is the criteria
element of the idea is too big?
When you're brainstorming,
trying to find out ideas.
Is there communication of when--
because I think, after today,
we won't get to see the
sixth graders anymore.
AUDIENCE: Well, you
have us and each other.
AUDIENCE: I think
the litmus test
that I used when producing
Science Out Loud-- I didn't
mention this yesterday, but it
was probably the first thing
I should've said.
Because there are no best
practices established
in this field, take
everything that we
present to you in class with a
grain of salt. And [INAUDIBLE].
So what I've found
with distilling
a big idea is that when I'm
scripting with a student,
and we start to go down a
rabbit hole, so we're saying,
well what is a
computer made out of?
Well, I have to
talk about a switch.
Then I have to
talk about binary.
Then I have to do this.
And we have somehow
found ourselves
down a rabbit hole that is
tangential to the core topic
at hand.
That's always been
an indication for me
that the core topic is too big.
And you examine
the branches that
are possible from
that core topic,
and start looking at, well, what
can I do from a branch, itself.
We can talk about
this more-- because I
know Natalie has to leave.
Does anyone have any
final questions for her?
Her email address
is on the syllabus.
NATALIE KULDELL: I'd
be happy to talk.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was curious, I guess
you worked with the sixth grade,
and many different teachers.
Are they conflicting advice
that is being given you?
NATALIE KULDELL:
Yes, but I think
that's because teachers teach
in many different settings.
And so what is true in one
setting is false in another.
There are some schools
that won't show YouTube,
that have that site blocked.
There are other teachers that
teach every day with YouTube.
So it's just every teaching
setting is really--
there's a wide range of--
AUDIENCE: Somehow you never
get to make a decision--
AUDIENCE: Standards
are the same.
NATALIE KULDELL: Yes, right,
so what they have to reach.
AUDIENCE: It may be different
where you are, but at least
here, in public settings,
and in some private settings,
the teachers have
uniform goals that they
each have to achieve in each
academic year for each student.
And it's a national
standard in public schools
that all sixth graders
must do these big topics.
And so within that,
how to teach those,
that's the common
thread in that.
NATALIE KULDELL: Yes, right.
But in terms of using
animation-- so the question
I thought was more related
to the tone of the video
that you're making,
and that is hard,
because teachers have
very different students,
and teachers are very different
people, one from the other.
Some are very
comfortable teaching
with animated characters,
some think that it
undermines their authority.
And I've heard both.
So it really-- for
better or worse,
I tend to just make a
decision and go with it.
This goes back to if I
knew then what I know now.
I think small, smart steps
is really the only way
to figure this out.
Anyway, and with that,
I really do have to go.
And I'm sorry, but
I'd be happy to talk
with you guys offline, OK?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.